I'm not sure it's what I should be best
known for but I'm best known for as
being one of the first to really say
that the Bush administration was not to
be trusted so I was the first certainly
the first major newspaper or op-ed
typewriter to to say that because I said
it even before the even before the two
thousand election was held so I can go
back and point you two columns from from
the summer of 2000 that I think for
shadow at least for shadow of the way
most people now think about the bush
administration before there even was a
bush administration I knew some things
that most journalists don't like
arithmetic and so I was looking at the
policy proposals and I just said they're
lying they're there they're not being
honest about what it is they're
proposing and that was a pretty good
guide to me it seemed to me that was
that was much better evidence than
whether Bush seem like a guy that you
want to have a beer with Social Security
which was basically counting the same
couple of trillion dollars twice he was
saying we can have it available to pay
benefits but we can also invest it and
you'll get lots of money out of it and
it didn't that didn't make sense on
taxes he was claiming that his tax cuts
favored the middle class and you could
do the math they didn't they were very
much tilted towards the top and and
there were a bunch of other things
smaller things but just the the clear
dishonesty about what was actually in
his own policy proposals and being the
kind of guy I am if you're lying about
the numbers that to me is you know
though it's not really the worst offense
but it's the clearest sign that you're
not a man you should be that the public
should trust it's it's crazy right this
you're in fact you are not going to have
a beer with the president what you want
to somebody you can trust around the
nation